en este vídeo quiero utilizar todo lo
que aprendimos en el vídeo pasado para
probar que esta sucesión converge al 0
es decir que el límite cuando n tiende a
infinito de esta sucesión que habíamos
construido de menos 1 elevado a la n 1
entre n cuando entiende infinito este
límite es igual a 0 y para esto voy a
utilizar justo lo que vi en el vídeo
pasado pero antes de recordar la
definición de que justo esto pase pues
quiero que veas que eso tiene todo el
sentido lógico del mundo yo me tomo esta
expresión date cuenta que la parte de
arriba lo que está haciendo es dando
unos valores positivos negativos
positivos negativos mientras que la
parte de abajo se hace cada vez más
grande por lo tanto intuitivamente esta
expresión se va a cero pero vamos a
recordar lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado
en el vídeo pasado vimos esta definición
dice si para toda épsilon más grande que
0 existe una m más grande que 0 tal que
si n es más grande que m si tomamos una
n más grande que m entonces el valor
absoluto
n l es menor que epsilon pero en este
caso el l va a ser cero porque es justo
donde quiero converger entonces si
tomamos cualquier n más grande que m
entonces a n menos cero en valor
absoluto es menor que epsilon entonces
decimos que el límite de esta sucesión
es igual a cero que esta sucesión
convergen en cero y justo aquí está en
el valor de cero y lo que quiero es que
te des cuenta de que es lo que me está
diciendo esta definición vamos a
tomarnos una épsilon positiva vamos a
suponer que esta es mi eps la positiva y
déjeme hacerlo un poco más congruente mi
dibujo vamos a poner aquí a esta épsilon
y por lo tanto aquí tengo cero menos
sección aquí tengo cero más opción
recuerda que cero es justo este valor al
que yo quiero converger y vamos a
analizar lo que me dice esta oración si
para toda épsilon mayor que cero existe
m mayor que cero tal que si tomamos una
n más grande que m entonces pasa esto
justo lo que me está diciendo es que si
yo me tomo una m más grande que 0 vamos
a suponer que está m es 2 entonces para
todos los valores más grandes que 2
ya que hay de la solución al cero tiene
que ser menor que épsilon es decir todos
los puntos a partir del 2 tienen que
caer en este rango pero esto es para
toda épsilon entonces dada a una eps i
l'ombre tengo que encontrar una m de tal
manera que todos los puntos a partir de
esa m caigan en ese rango pero bueno qué
es lo que necesito para que esta
expresión que tengo aquí sea verdad que
por cierto es justo lo que quiero que se
cumpla esta expresión es decir que el
valor absoluto
dehaene menos 0 esto sea menor que
épsilon y bueno a n menos cero pues es
justo lo mismo que tomando el valor
absoluto de a n yo lo que quiero es que
el valor absoluto de ã n sea menor que
epsilon y que es necesario para que se
cumpla esto bueno a n es lo mismo que
menos 1 elevado a la n 1 entre no el
valor absoluto de esto es justo lo que
quiero que sea menor que epsilon
ahora bien date cuenta que no es
expresión pasa algo importante menos 1
elevado a la n 1 es esencialmente tomar
dos valores menos 1 y 1 y después de que
me tomo el valor absoluto de menos 1 y
de 1 esto me da 1 por lo tanto esto
lo que decir que es lo que necesito es
tomarme el valor absoluto de 1 entre n y
que esto sea menor que épsilon
sin embargo n siempre es positiva porque
en esta definidas los naturales por lo
tanto el valor absoluto de 1 entre en es
lo mismo que 1 entre n entonces yo lo
que necesito es que uno entre n sea
menor que epsilon y ahora si me tomo un
recíproco de ambos lados de esta
desigualdad la desigualdad se voltea es
decir que yo lo que quiero es que n sea
más grande que el recíproco de épsilon
el recíproco de épsilon es uno entre
épsilon es decir que esta es justa mi
condición necesaria que n sea más grande
que uno entre épsilon y bueno esto ya lo
hemos probado varias veces y de hecho lo
podemos probar justo ahorita yo lo que
quiero es que en él sea más grande que
uno entre épsilon esto ya es un gran
paso porque fíjate bien si tú me das
cualquier épsilon
yo voy a bautizar a m como 1 / épsilon y
por lo tanto si yo me fijo en todas las
sedes que son más grandes que m entonces
todos los puntos van a caer en esta
región y yo lo que quiero es que para
toda n más grande que m pero m es igual
a 1 entre épsilon entonces n va a ser
más grande que
/ épsilon se cumpla que el valor
absoluto de n 0 sea menor que épsilon
que justo es lo que pasan dado como
acabo de construir todo esto siempre que
se cumpla que n sea más grande que uno
entre épsilon entonces va a pasar que a
en menos 0 un valor absoluto va a ser
menor que épsilon y justo esto es lo que
quiero para que existe el límite así que
imagínate que en este ejemplo si yo me
tomo que épsilon es igual a un medio
entonces él me tiene que ser igual a 2
es decir el recíproco de un medio en més
igualados y date cuenta que a partir del
2 para cualquier n más grande que 2
todos estos puntos van a existir en esta
región o dicho otra manera la distancia
que hay de estos puntos al 0 va a ser
menor que épsilon y fíjate que si se
cumple ahora bien si tú quisieras para
otra épsilon tú dame esta épsilon y yo
voy a hacer a m igual a 1 entre épsilon
y entonces para cualquier n que sea más
grande que m se va a cumplir que los
puntos de la sucesión van a caer en esa
región y esto es justo lo que acabamos
de probar que si funciona este límite y
que entonces esta sucesión con bergé al
c